many people within number 10 have
received these fixed penalty notices and
now also the prime minister and the
chancellor we need an apology from every
single person that's received a fixed
penalty notice and the prime minister
has to
answer
why he has acted in this way and
received this sanction from the met
police
you call them concerns from what i've
been reading online and from people i've
spoken to in the weeks and months we've
been covering this partygate scandal is
there is anger people couldn't be with
their loved ones when they died they
weren't allowed to go to funerals they
weren't allowed to meet up with people
and were living on their own for months
the prime minister had a birthday party
yes and that's exactly what i said in in
response to your opening remarks here
there was at the time this first came to
light at the tail end of last year and
early on this year anger fury and that
is
you know still there now in very high
levels and i fully
understand accept and share all of that
calls for him to resign not only has he
been found to break the law
but in subsequent
speeches to parliament and talking to
the public via media outlets like sky
news he repeatedly denied rules were
broken
and you know
your viewers will know i previously
called for the prime minister
to step down it was at the time when we
found out that these birthday parties
were
had happened and that came to light
but since then we have seen something
that
i never thought i would see in my
lifetime another war
in europe between russia and ukraine
that illegal and unjust invasion
and innocent people being targeted by
russian troops
and murdered we've got reports this
morning of the us and the uk
investigating claims that there may have
been chemical weapons used in ukraine
all of that for me changes the situation
right so you don't think the prime
minister should resign because there is
a war in ukraine you don't you don't
think the prime minister should resign
because there is war in ukraine i mean
i've had tweets from people saying for
goodness sake we changed the prime
minister during world war ii you can't
just keep a prime minister who has lied
to the public and to parliament who has
broken the law because there is war in
europe
well you will know that when there was a
previous change during world wars that
the rules for changing a leader were
quite different and it could be done
just by mps alone now it's a process
that goes out to party members and takes
several months however i was also saying
there that
the leadership
has been welcomed by president zielinski
you saw with the walkabout around
between president zilenski and the prime
minister at the weekend just how
important that
relationship between the uk and ukraine
is at the moment the support we're
giving to the people in ukraine to
defend their country you could argue
that president zolensky is putting on a
united front to get what he wants from
the uk if president zalensky wants
support from the uk he will deal with
whoever is presented to him it's not
because he's mates with boris johnson
well it's nothing about being mates he
has seen that the prime minister and the
uk government have delivered where other
governments in other parts of europe and
across the world have not he has
president zielinski singled out the
prime minister for the support he has
received
from the uk be it in military assistance
be it in sanctions that have been
imposed and the support that we are
providing to the people of ukraine to
defend their freedoms and their country
so you want the prime minister to remain
in place for the moment do you want him
to lead you into the next election
well i'm not getting into any
hypotheticals what i've said today is uh
as there is a war or it's not
hypothetical there will be another
general election there will be another
general election at some point we don't
know when do you want boris johnson to
lead the conservatives in that
and and what i'm saying is at the moment
when we are dealing with this ongoing
crisis the focus has to be on that
because the only person who benefits
from any
destabilization here in the uk is
vladimir putin and i don't want to do
anything
to
benefit a war criminal like putin so
you're not committed to boris johnson
leading the conservatives into the next
general election it's quite a simple
question
well you know we don't know where we
will be in a couple of years time when
the next general election is due i'm
looking at the situation right now i'm
looking at where we were just a few
months ago when i previously
spoke out against the prime minister and
i'm looking at where we are now things
change a lot in a very short period of
time where we are now you would be happy
for him to lead the conservatives at the
next election
based on what's happening now he's been
found to be bringing us where we are now
is
what what is happening at the moment is
there is a war in europe where we need
to have all our support united behind
the people of ukraine
okay but i would just like a clear
answer as we stand now there is a war in
europe the prime minister has broken the
law and is being punished as such the
first sitting prime minister to be
punished for breaking the law you would
be happy for him to lead the
conservatives to the next general
election
i'm saying it's right that he remains in
post for this war is ongoing and we need
to provide support to president zilensky
and the people of ukraine support that
has been welcomed by the president and
people in ukraine and people from
ukraine
okay does the chancellor have your
backing
the chancellor has questions to answer
on this as well and i say it again i
think in response to your first question
that every single person has received a
fixed penalty notice has to apologize
for that and explain their actions
because you're right you know at the
time that there was this party that
they've now been found over people were
following the rules every single rule
that was put in place
okay douglas ross thank you very much
indeed leader of the scottish
conservatives his reaction there to the
breaking news today
about the prime minister and the
chancellor being fined
for
breaching covered regulations